so
[Music]
this notion of spirit that knows itself
as spirit is itself the immediate notion
and is not yet developed absolute being
is spirit that is it has appeared it is
revealed this first revelation is itself
immediate but the immediacy is equally
pure mediation or thought and it must
therefore exhibit this in its own sphere
as such
looking at this more closely spirit in
the immediacy of self-consciousness is
this individual self-consciousness and
so in an antithesis to the universal
self-consciousness
it is an exclusive one or unit which has
the still unresolved form of a sensuous
other for the consciousness for which it
is immediately present the other does
not as yet know spirit on its own that
is spirit as an individual self is not
yet equally the universal self the self
of everyone in other words the shape is
not as yet the form of the notion that
is of the universal self of the self
that in its immediate actuality is at
the same time a superseded self that is
thought universality without losing its
actuality in this universality but the
proximate form of this universality the
form that is itself immediate is not yet
the form of thought itself of the notion
as notion but the universality of
reality the allness or totality of the
selves and the raising of existence into
an ideational form
as in every case and to cite a specific
example the superseded this of sense is
in the first place the thing of
perception not yet the universal of the
understanding
paragraph
762 seems rather short and at first
glance there's not all that much going
on there but this is actually a really
important turning point coming after
several other very important turning
points so i think we want to devote some
pretty close analysis to this and when
we look at where it ends up
in the reference to the consciousness
section right the
this of sense
the thing of perception and the
universal of the understanding
that i think takes some unpacking to
completely
get at what hegel's doing there there's
a nice you know three-part schema but
i think we want to dig in and dive in a
little bit
and and
explicate that for ourselves
so that we fully understand what's going
on there is of course
flowing from this paragraph into the
next
a close connection
that's happening
and actually the subsequent paragraphs
particularly on this theme of for
stellang that is representation or as
miller is translating it here in terms
of
ideational form and maybe we have to
talk a little bit about how we translate
for stellang in this because he's also
translating it you know just afterwards
as
picture thinking you know we we can also
bring in representation so anyway
there's there's a lot going on here so
let's look at the
text itself we had in the previous
paragraphs
a number of different things being
brought together
in the revealed religion in the
individual
human being and you know reading between
the lines here this is jesus christ the
christ of of the you know religion
christianity which hegel takes to be the
absolute the you know the ultimate
religion
not as good as philosophy by the way
something that you know kierkegaard and
others would sometimes criticize him for
and actually this is a little bit of a
digression here if you want to criticize
hegel's views on religion
there are a number of different ways you
can do this a number of at least on the
surface
weaknesses or
vulnerable points and you know one of
these
would be to say well what's so special
about christianity
and that's what hegel's been trying to
push here
in these previous paragraphs it's
different in that you don't just have a
god who's up on high who you know you
relate to through priests or other
mediators or maybe through your own uh
community or your minds or artistic
production or artistic consumption
you relate to this as a sensuous
human being and you could say well
that's all fine and good but hegel you
weren't there at the
you know the crucifixion you're relying
on all these texts and he would say yeah
i know i mean
i actually wrote something earlier in my
career about these sorts of problems
there's there's the issue of the higher
criticism developing how do we know
anything about this he's going to talk
about that in subsequent paragraphs
right
but you could also say well what's so
what's so great about having an
individual human being here
representing things and that's another
area where you know hegel i think has
some responses
you could say well what about other
religions in which there is a
human not just intercessor
but somebody who is
you know the divine incarnate well
that's another interesting uh question
to raise maybe there's
not something so unique about
christianity or the western
consciousness and hegel doesn't take
that into adequate account
but another charge that you do see
kierkegaard making is all right hegel
you're right you know christianity is
really important religion is really
central why are you placing that before
philosophy and essentially saying
religion is for the dummies who have to
use picture language the the real action
is in the notion or the concept you know
what is warranting you to to do that and
so
back to again to the text and thinking
about this
if we
look at what he's um
telling us here
so we
to back up a little bit in the previous
paragraphs we had this
incarnate god
and what what it was bringing together
was you could say a kind of uh not you
know the equivalent of a a triad is a
quatra nod i guess so we'll say a
four-foldedness
of being sein
essence vasen
uh existence design and thought denkins
and
these are
connected together
related to each other and yet at the
same time distinct from each other as we
again saw in the previous paragraphs
hegel is still playing off of these
now
as i pointed out in the earlier
paragraphs denkin thinking assumes an
absolutely
central role
but we can say well what kind of thought
right and here is where we might
see something really
valuable
in this four stellum versus
or representation
versus uh begriff notion or concept
distinction that hegel is making and
it's not just a distinction it's also a
movement it's also a transition as we're
going to see so we're going to come back
to that in in just a bit
let's begin at the beginning
this notion of spirit all right so the
begin of geist this the spirit has a
notion of itself that knows itself as
spirit right spirit knowing itself as
spirit this is something
very important it's attained a certain
kind of articulateness it has gone
through a number of we can call them
supersessions or you know
transformations the these
alf haven right going from one
shape of consciousness one gestalt to
another
and from you know developing the concept
in in the process spirit is you know
what what fundamentally is for hegel so
spirit becoming conscious of itself
through religion is going to be really
quite important but notice what he says
right after that
is itself the
immediate when methyl boros right
unmediated
or not mediating notion and
as such
is not yet developed
now
relative term here not yet developed
right is it completely crude you know
are we way way back at the beginning of
you know
putative human history with
self-consciousnesses running into each
other looking for recognition no no
we've we've traversed a massive path
throughout you know
millennia of history and cultural
development right building we've
developed spirit through all these
different forms of itself through which
it got to know itself so we're not we're
not at the beginning we're we're but
we're not at the and yet and there is a
certain immediacy a certain
undevelopedness to this concept here
that is still going to be
the actual case the virtual kite
but it is not going to be
what is possible what is being sketched
out the where we ought to be going
so he says absolute being and now here
miller is taking a little bit of liberty
it just says vasen vase and essence
being
is
has appeared
it is revealed
and okay
is it that big of a liberty no because
we are talking about the absolute here
and so it's appeared uh it's shining
shining right so it has
shown itself forth right to to who
that's a good question we're gonna have
to ask in a moment
and it is revealed now the reveal the ed
ending in english makes it sound like
something did the revealing
something self-revealed again i've
pointed this out open bar it is in the
form of that which is revealed it is
opened up to
us
so
who has it been revealed to the
the community the individuals
who saw god face to face and recognized
god as such if only dimly if not fully
worked out i mean if we're going to
think about christianity
think about the gospels if you've ever
read them it's not as if this jesus you
know fellow is born and they have a nice
christmas and you know the three wise
men come and then you know boom he
suddenly uh well there's in luke at
least there's a passage where he's a
teenager right and he's in his father's
house where were you well i was you know
hanging out in the temple and then boom
we're there when he's 30 and now he's
wandering around preaching to people and
he tells you know for example simon
peter and andrew hey follow me right and
they're like
okie doke i got a good thriving fish
business here but i'll just leave it
behind and you said so it's not you know
when we talk about immediacy it's not
that immediate read the gospels and one
of the things that you see
is a
not constant but continual
not fully recognizing what the hell's
going on and who this guy is
and how he's connected with with god
right uh at one point um
jesus actually tells peter who's like
you know the the big guy
uh hey get behind me satan you're you're
messing stuff up right and one of the uh
apostles is you know so
mixed up that he actually sells jesus
out at one point so there's a lot of
ways to go wrong with this
even when things are being appeared and
being revealed
now notice the next thing that he says
here and here this hearkens back to
something i said in a previous paragraph
about immediacy
this first revelation is itself
immediate unmediated right it's boom
right there in your face you could
imagine this jesus guy instead of being
like you know out there in a row boat
preaching to the crowds and stuff like
that imagine him being there you know in
the the backstage if we're gonna use
musical metaphors and he's talking with
his his friends his companions these
followers and he's like right there in
their face you know face to face where
you can smell the the garlic on
somebody's breath and he's telling them
things you know and they're
communicating well that's pretty
immediate isn't it but even then there's
still
mediatedness or media c
he says this immediacy
is equally pure mediation
okay so
that's something that we can say
anytime that hegel brings up the
immediate the immediate never remains
purely immediate if you know if you
haven't gotten that lesson by this time
at least hopefully this time it clicks
nothing is ever completely immediate at
least not for long and what
shows us
that's
that's the case that it's not
purely immediate
thought as soon as we start thinking
about things there is mediation going on
and hegel right here in the rest of this
sentence is saying okay it is equally
pure mediation
or thought thought is a mediating
function
and it must therefore exhibit this in
its own sphere as such what now why does
it have to exhibit it in its own sphere
as such
well because when you start thinking
about things that changes what you're
working with and now you have to take
into account what you're thinking about
and
you know there's you could say a certain
adequacy
that needs to happen here and you know
this brings up something else that is
not being talked about here but
think about
the nature of truth within the hegelian
dialectic it's tempting to say oh well i
know all about that hegel is a not
correspondence theory of truth person
but rather a coherence theory the truth
is in the whole the totality you know
the gods the the entirety of everything
and everything has to be connected to it
that's that's part of hegelian truth but
there's also another sense in which
truth is
an adequation but an ongoing dialectical
adequation between
our thinking and what we're encountering
including our thinking about ourselves
including our thinking about god
so
quite important here
so he goes on and he says
looking at this more closely and now we
get to you know the schema that i've got
sketched out here
spirit
in the immediacy of self-consciousness
right so we've got
an immediacy of self-consciousness
self-consciousness taking itself as
immediate
is this thesis individual einstein
self-consciousness
and so it's in an antithesis
it's in an opposition
with the universal self-consciousness
and this universal term here is going to
be very important to unpack as well
algamina right what does that actually
mean
an antithesis to the universal
self-consciousness
it is an exclusive one or unit which has
the still unresolved form of a sensuous
other
for the consciousness which for which it
is immediately present and here we gotta
like shift things around a bit right one
and other this goes back to the nature
of self-consciousness self-consciousness
is
itself you know what it is through
another self-consciousness it is in its
relation to its other and the same goes
for the other self-consciousness it is
what it is in relation to the one or the
other other
self-consciousness and so there's some
flipping back and forth here and it
doesn't actually map on completely right
because
who are we referencing here are we
talking about the
self-consciousness the individual self
of the
god revealing itself is incarnate as god
human the you know uh god become man to
take anselm's you know wonderful title
why god became man curtis homo
or are we talking about the
self-consciousness of the
worshiper the acknowledger the follower
the believer
well
it's kind of both isn't it and we could
actually play this out
on both sides
maybe we will maybe we we won't maybe
i'll just leave that for you to
think through
let's go on a little bit further right
so he says
this other does not as yet no spirit as
its own
that is and this is what suggests to us
maybe we should think of it in terms of
the believer right
spirit as an individual self is not yet
equally now here's where he's starting
to sketch out what the universal self
looks like
is not yet equally the universal self
the self of everyone
now
this is an interesting way to talk about
it not the self of the community right
not the self of the totality the godside
rather the self of everyone alice all
the other self-consciousnesses so should
this be understood as something you know
kind of uh
hazy like a general will allah rousseau
or you know somebody speaking for it no
this is like a a
bunch of different people
having selves and being together in a
community and maybe something emerges
from it maybe something doesn't but
there is definitely an opposition
between the individual
and everybody else although the
individual is part of everybody else so
you know
maybe they haven't yet recognized that
they're part of every this everybody
else you know they're part of everybody
and there's you know
viewed as
there's a universality here there's a
particularity or individuality here and
the universality should in some respect
matter more
we also have going on here so this
actually could be
the religious revealer
who doesn't fully yet
grasp what he is
because there's an opposition between
him and his self-consciousness
and the everybody else
isn't that a suggestive idea you know
and this would go against notions where
jesus
of nazareth as you know the second
person of the trinity the son is just
like knows everything from the start
there is a tension here in christianity
as a religion that's one that's very
much reflected in the gospels right and
also reflected in the various letters
you know this guy
suffers seems to learn things along the
way very smart as well
speaks with authority and yet
doesn't actually
totally over master
the community doesn't come in and
everyone's like oh listen to this guy
now we re-center the community
completely around him it takes work
right
so we go on and here this is a wonderful
phrase in other words
the shape the gestalt
has not yet the form of the notion
the grief that is of the universal self
of the self
that in its immediate actuality
is at the same time a superseded
alcoholist
self that is
thought
universality
without losing its actuality in this
universality now is that what we're
getting out of the
community no something else is being
sketched something else is being
projected
out there
uh something that within the hegelian
dialectic is is there sort of like as a
draw think of it like
how aristotle talks about god is that
which draws other things to it right as
a final end
but this isn't being
fully understood
in that thinking although thought is the
way in which this is going to
attain some level
of understanding and this is where i
think we get to the most
important and interesting
parts of this right otherwise we have
this this cool dialectic or opposition
between individual and community wow
that's awesome we can learn something
from that
we can also learn something from that
not just generally but in terms of
thinking about you know the christian
community the early christian community
and how they what they made of this
person who they're supposed to believe
in and trust in and who's teaching them
that's all really great but we add in
this other element and you could say the
bottom drops out right or rather
something else is restored to what we're
seeing so this entire dialectic here
between individual and the universal is
spirit coming to you know coming to know
itself um
absolute being as spirit revealing
itself
and it has a universality
algae mine height
now i've said this before in the past
when we see universality
universality is
in some respects a relative term right
it's relative to the
particulars or individuals that it takes
in but it's also a relative term in that
you can have more or less universality
we can talk of a universality capital u
versus a universality lowercase u or if
we wanted to sort of paraphrase kant
think back to the groundwork for the
metaphysics of morals right where kahn
says listen um
morality not about happiness you know
that's not the whole point of it
um but we can have
ma we can't
what is it rules uh not maxims because
the maxims are actually for for the
universal the the morality we can have
you know guidelines you could say of
prudence
right and prudence is directing us
towards happiness gluckly kite
and
you can have some general rules like
don't piss all your money away at the
casino right that's a pretty specific
one don't waste your money is a little
bit more uh universal right but there
might be cases where you actually do
have to waste your money in order to
attain happiness so it's a general it's
it's a rule of thumb as opposed to the
true
universal which for kant means
exceptionless right so there's a
universality generality
specificity distinction it's almost like
a continuum
there except maybe there's like a
dividing line to universality
higgle's saying something kind of like
that
right
the universality
of the the universal self-consciousness
is not yet full universality
algaminite right
and so he's going to bring in a number
of things here he's going to talk about
actuality
vehicly kite the allness the all height
of the selves he's going to talk about
raising existence into ideational form
you could say transformation of dozens
of existence into
representation which by itself not a bad
thing this is a really awesome thing
but it's not where we should be ending
right
all of this requires
to be
sublated or superseded
alkahobin right and so
it requires some auf haven going on but
the way that hegel talks about this is
alf gehlben uh you know as if it's
almost like past tense although you know
a past i mean it is past tense for us
isn't it we think about this right these
transformations have taken place not
just in our past but in hegel's past so
i guess that makes perfect sense and
what are we trying to get to
the form of thought itself
right um we have to get to the notion
as
notion the grief also grief
so
not just the big if the notion that we
started with here but the real full
thing remember how hegel at the very
beginning of this says that um
here we go it's not yet developed
spirit is not yet developed it's
appeared it's revealed
but we don't have the notion completely
unfolded yet we got to unfold that
notion and that's what happens over here
in the more universal universality
and so hegel is going to give us
something
like a
analogy
or you could even say
reading backwards an allegory
i mean i hadn't thought about that but
maybe the consciousness section really
is an allegory for what's supposed to be
happening here an allegory is a story
that tells another story right doesn't
mean that the original story is false
but it means that
there's more going on that the story can
tell a better greater story and perhaps
that's what's happening so he tells us
that
to cite a specific example the
superseded the alpha hobana this of
sense right in sense certainty is in the
first place the thing of perception
and not yet the universal
of understanding now the thing of
perception the thing of perception is a
universal
right it's there's a universal in
uh the different qualities and the thing
itself can be looked at as a universal
both in the the development of it and as
the example that hegel's using but it's
it's definitely not the universal of
that
most difficult section of the
phenomenology force and the
understanding where we bring in
forces and laws and even worlds to make
sense of things there's a there's a
greater complexity there's a
notion of notion being spelled out in
that is isn't there and so we can say
well this is kind of like that send
certainty right immediacy then we have
the community itself and we've got this
cool interplay between the two of them
which can be modeled in terms of
individual relations within the
community but also something greater a
universality going beyond it but that
universality
like the thing with its properties is
not yet the whole universality the
capital u
universality that we're going to get
when we move to what force and the
understanding or in this case what are
we moving to
well the next paragraphs i mean hegel is
going to be saying ultimately
that
the community has to
re-understand itself widen itself
and that this this key
person incarnate god is going to play a
role in that i don't want to give away
the ending of course spoilers but let's
linger just for a second on
this um
distinction foreshadowing
and uh big grief or
ideational
uh form
representation
uh picture thinking
and um notion now picture thinking for
hegel that is where foreshadowing
picture thinking or ideational form
isn't always the best translation that
works for some things particularly where
the visual is involved
but we can also
say that this is a schematic way of
understanding right so
if i mean in a certain respect it's
ironic here because anything you can
really sketch on the blackboard is not
the notion right the notion has to be in
our heads so to speak and in our
discourse and our relation with the text
and our relation with what's on the
chalkboard what's on the chalkboard is
basically just for stone but it's
foreshadowing that can be helpful
in understanding what's what's actually
happening foreshadowing that can be used
as a tool to get us beyond mere
foreshadowing and this is where
this is where i'm going to end up this
you know elf haven this sublation
or supersession is really really
important to keep in mind we are not
moving from foreshelling and saying get
rid of all that crap we're going to be
mystics and like just intuit god or
something like that
hegel is not for that at all
for stellang had better be incorporated
and it had better be given a greater
context and we'd better remain in
relation to it and yet not reduce the
religious object that we're grasping
to mere foreshtellon this is very very
different than
saying well we leave forshelling behind
because it's no good for selling is very
very good it's just not
as good as we'd like it to be so
that's yeah you can see there's a lot
going on in this paragraph when we
really start digging into it
you